part of you know the work that I do
especially in Africa about you know with
the foundation that I founded the Africa
education initiative is centered around
health care and education for Africa's
children we have essentially offices on
blades on officers in about four or five
countries in Africa Nigeria Ghana
Liberia Cameroon we've also have work
that we've done with students in Kenya
you know we're hoping to go to South
Africa next week and the programs we
write are all student-centered and
geared towards children to provide them
the basic needs that they need a what
that they need for the education
everything from scholarship programs to
curriculum enhancement programs
technology enhancements at the sublime
donated computers Bisons been a big help
you know donating these laptops to us
and we in turn make sure that the
students and the schools and you have
them and use them in Africa and and then
the public health education and public
health program which has been a very big
success for our our foundation recently
about a year and a half ago we a partner
with Pfizer to start a health care
clinic in rural Nigeria in a town rural
village called ovum and this is about
20,000 people in that community there
was absolutely no health center there
for them that would have to drive or
walk miles to just see a doctor and we
you know went over there and helped them
set up a primary health care facility
and so a lot of patients while we're
there and this health care facility
staffed with doctors nurses
or partner with the local government
there to provide those services and it
is a hope that this you know would
continue to be open a week we have since
transferred the management of that
facility back to the community but it
was a one of a greatest achievement and
and then the other one is the one we
started the first one of the very first
of prevention of mother to child care
programs in Liberia a country that's
been in civil war for four years and we
partner with Global Strategy out of
California and that provided test kits
for testing hiv/aids for patients the
mothers of pregnant mothers and
providing the variant to these pregnant
mothers and suspension for their babies
in order to manage this very critical
and very devastating disease an ef3
dot-org so Nancy Edward Frank the number
three dot o-r-g and you know it's a
nonprofit organization based here and a
501 C 3 we always looking for help
people to volunteer to help us with the
mission and objectives and and if you
cannot help you know we're also looking
for you know donations you know and you
can send tax-deductible contribution to
the foundation